the questions you're going to ask are
going to determine a lot for me so
go for it
got it i'm now feeling a lot of pressure
i i'm going to break the streak and not
ask about zodiac today because i want to
talk about this movie so just it's not
about zodiac it's just i now i know i
feel like i know your line of questions
we've been we've done a lot of questions
about many different movies and i know
i just i'm not gonna tell you what i'm
gonna say i'll tell you in person when i
see you but i just i i know now go go
for it anyway
got it i feel like i have so many
questions right now um so uh i love i'm
gonna throw out a curveball at the
beginning um for both of you first of
all congrats on this movie and i have a
lot of questions um if you could each
get the financing to make anything you
want what would you make and why
um
i'm looking at jake and i'm like i'm
debating if he's thinking this is what i
was gonna ask you know what he did he
went he opened an encrypted file of
questions he's always wanted to ask as i
said that and he asked that question
um he's like oh god oh oh no no i got my
questions in front of me this was coming
no matter what
that's a hard one for me you know that's
a hard one for a filmmaker because
there's a lot of subjects that i think i
would love to
to uh explore
but uh
yeah that's a tough one steve i threw a
curveball right at the beginning that's
a tough one i don't have an answer for
you on that one that's a tough one
by the way i know i owe you a t-shirt i
haven't forgotten yeah you do that's
right i know
no by the way i had it in my brain
this is what i mean you're like you're
dealing with a vault a man who has a
vault of relationships that are so
amazing and he's like i owe you a
t-shirt fuqua and gyllenhaal don't worry
i'll i'll i'll i'll give you that can of
pickles you know it's like
the fact you remember it is amazing
i
i would say um
i'm just not that kind of i'm just not
that kind of uh actor or artist i i
i don't know if there's something that i
deeply desire
to play from afar i i
i believe that things kind of come to
you so
that's my feeling just i lay and wait
sure
the thing i would imagine when you guys
were researching to make this film you
must have learned a lot about 9-1-1 call
centers is there anything that really
stuck out for you guys that you're like
oh my god i had no idea and we have to
incorporate this
for me what stuck out would you you
would think is an obvious thing right
these these you're incredible people
they really are and the fact that
sometimes these uh
your
your worst day in your life happens and
they're experiencing it with you and
helping you through it but sometimes
they don't even know the result
of you know if a kid is safe or not safe
or you know the person lived or died
they just move on to the next call
and i found that to just be
uh
amazing and what strength that would
take to because you're taking on all
that emotion you take that home with you
um
i found them to be amazing people
you know
i would have to totally agree with
antoine on that just like so many
unresolved cadences for these people you
know
and that they
and sometimes they get to know but most
of the time they don't and they continue
to think about that picking up a phone
call
knowing you'll never know really what's
going to happen particularly if it's
very serious
it's just
to go through that and come back every
day
is a pretty incredible feat yeah
uh i've read and it could be wrong that
you made this film in like 10 days or
nine days
a number that's very very low um i just
have to know how the f did you pull that
off
you know i couldn't even tell you right
now you know we just
we just did it you know it just felt
it felt like it's something that needed
to happen
right the haida covet
the story was compelling
uh i was available for a short period
jake was available for a short period um
we just had to make it work
and it really is a credit to
our industry and the people that work in
our industry that everybody came on
board
art director and production designers
and dps i mean everybody jumped on this
movie to make it work knowing we were
under a pressure of time during covet to
keep everybody safe so i think it was
just one of those things where we just
we just did it
we just sort of yeah i mean it was part
of the whole thing i mean i
i had always thought it should be shot
in a very short period of time i just
i felt like you know you each piece
presents its own challenges and tells
you what it is and i thought from the
very beginning and it was how i pitched
it to antoine was
i know you're not available but we can
do this in five days you know
and and uh that would be really fun
don't you think and uh we both do like a
challenge but
i think it was sort of baked into the
process and into the story from the jump
that it
you know i don't know how much you could
indulge a story like that you know um
it needed to be done
with a time clock and that time clock
needed to be very short and that
pressure and that tension we thought we
were doing it is all in the movie too
uh jake i i really sincerely love your
work as an actor all all kidding all the
[ __ ] we've just you know joked
around about and i am curious for you
like say you know in this film
especially with the performance you have
to give say you have a really emotional
or dramatic scene on a monday and you
know it's going to take it out of you
can you sort of tell me how you're
preparing to deliver a performance like
that for that monday are you days in
advance breaking it down is it the day
before that you're really getting in
your head like what is it like for you
the night before when you're you know
sleeping on it good question um i
believe that things take a long long
time you know i i think you have to
you have to not just do hard work all
the time diving in deep every day you
over analyze and you
undo what could be alive you know so i
like have these weird things i believe
you should
sometimes it's like you sleep with the
script by your bed and somehow there's
transference you know what i mean even
if you don't open it up you know um i
read a lot of books in high school that
way um but i also
but but i but i think that there's there
really is you know you work on something
and then you work on something in
particular and you let it go um then the
night before uh certain moments i think
i i often think about this too you know
with professional athlete or you know
what do they do the night before the
super bowl like do they sleep like i
wouldn't sleep like what's that about
i think when we're professionals of what
we do and i could ask the same thing of
both of you
you know you spend enough time doing it
that you you
can contextualize that you can that part
of the technique of what we all do when
we've done it for long enough is that we
can create space for our
work and then we can actually let it go
and that's something i've learned to do
over many years so a night before a very
intense scene
um
[Music]
i i have this feeling that i'm like
whatever's supposed to happen tonight
will happen if i'm not supposed to sleep
because i'm anxious about it and that's
what's supposed to happen if i do and i
sleep a lot i feel great that's weird
but
that's what's supposed to happen
and each thing is going to deliver me
that
it's obviously not the same thing as
being in the super bowl because you got
one shot um
there
and you have a lot of takes and you have
a great director who can fake it even if
you suck and
pull it out of the hat like antoine did
with this one but um
i uh
but it's it's a it's just about whatever
comes to you you know they're relaxing
into whatever it is
that's the easy stuff you get out into
your life when stuff becomes
actually dangerous and complicated and i
have no advice there but
and as for making a movie that that's
what i do
i have to stop there i'll just say jake
were any of those questions what you
expected
number one absolutely not um
but i now know and what i'm going to
reveal to you is that the questions you
ask is i know how you feel about a movie
and so that's
so it's because we've done a lot and i
usually feel very similar to you which
is interesting about the movie i'm in um
so i just it's it's uh it's just that's
you know just know it's not a one-way
street buddy you know i think you're
you're and netflix is gonna kill me but
you are um
a hundred percent i've had this from
other actor friends and they've told me
the second you start talking to me i
know if you like the movie
and it's
so great second then i'm like but you
guys listen i i was [ __ ] hook line
and sinker in this movie and it's
because jake is so good you know what i
mean like if you don't if jake's not
awesome in this it doesn't work i know
they're gonna they want me to leave i'll
see you guys later
good luck
i know next time i i didn't forget i
just this is virtual okay but don't send
it to me when i see you again it sounds
great
thank you guys